jeff snyder here with the team behind
may day which is uh premiering in
competition at the sundance film
festival i'm here with writer director
karen chinore stars grace van patten
havana rose lou and soco thanks for
joining us ladies
thank you karen let's start with you
tell me you know like
where did this come from because this is
i've never really
quite seen anything like this especially
at sundance
i guess that's a good thing uh i think
it
came it came from a lot of things but it
it came partly out of my obsession
as a girl with the wizard of oz i think
and
um always wanting to kind of make
a better one not that there's anything
wrong with the movie
i uh but i always felt sad that dorothy
came back
and they were like oh you didn't really
go anywhere at all
and you should have stayed home and i
just thought
no no she would be transformed when she
came back you know and
uh i think that was in the back of my
mind and
when i set out to create a story about a
young woman
coming of age um that was there
and then you know
i think also the brutal fact
is that young women and girls
worldwide experience some relationship
to violence
in their lives and so that affected the
way the story
was shaped and
i see these i see
actual women and girls as forces of
nature
so the wizard of oz idea
gave them a large canvas to
not be constrained by genre boundaries
and
allowed them to be the real forces of
nature
for the folks at home who you know
haven't seen a trailer yet may not know
what the film is about
can you describe it in your own words
the modern wizard of oz
about a young woman who's trying to find
her voice so
grace and soko and havana like you know
what made you want to sign on what drew
you to this
to the script and how do you each make
these characters your own
grace we'll start with you okay um
i i mean i i read the script and
and fell in love with it and and for so
many different reasons but i thought it
was so magical and i thought it was
it was so metaphorical and relevant and
it was it was done in such a fantastical
way um and the idea of working with all
women was so exciting to me
and just following this this character
on his journey and um just a story about
a young woman who's in a really place
and needs to find her inner strength
um and she does and i thought it was so
so hopeful
and so um inspiring to see that ending
and to
to give people hope when they watch it
as well i really felt
a lot of the same things you're talking
about grace in regard to just sort of
the path
that this film takes in exploring
femininity and power and femininity
and um i think for me there was also an
added benefit of this sort of catharsis
that i might feel
in being able to explore that as be as
my character as this sort of
manifestation of ana's inner child of
this part that
um can sort of provide hope
and love and is perhaps um
a bit more nuanced than just innocent
but truly has some sort of
hope and desire to um make some sort of
change within the structure that anna is
escaping
and i think that for me there was a lot
that when i initially read the script i
felt
kindred too there was a lot that i felt
like i could
sort of heal from by being a part of the
project and so i
i hope that other people watching it
will feel the same
i feel a lot of the similar things and
to not repeat i'm gonna say
one other thing that was attractive to
the project was karen
as an artist and also supporting her in
her first
effort to put something very special and
different out into the world
and um
it felt like a like we were speaking the
same language
in terms of what we want for women and
how we can support women and how we
could just like finally exist and like
take
our place and and assume it and
um and feel our power and
um and there was a lot of that on set
there was a lot of that in prep
there was a lot of that in our
conversation with karen and
our on and off on and off sets
um who
made it very um
safe for all of us and and
made us feel empowered all in
in very different ways but like i
i was personally terrified with guns i'm
i'm
really anti-guns and that was a really
big thing for me when i read the script
and i was like i don't want to shoot
guns and
and then we did it was really hard for
me like i felt like i had a weird ptsd
experience with
shooting a gun for the first time and
that was very hard to overcome but
then all the conversations i had with
karen were very reassuring that like she
was also anti-guns and she's not
she's completely anti-violence and this
is not what the movie is about and
she kept just like reframing it of like
it's not about that it's really about
the power of these women
and so that that was very something
special for me
karen i i wanted to sort of back up and
ask you what inspired you to become
a filmmaker uh and you know what your
path was since this is your first
feature film
you know how did you sort of work your
way up to it
i've been working on film for a long
time
um i never had the opportunity to make a
feature
but i've been making shorts and videos
and i've
have a strong dance background some
sound design
curating sort of worked on a lot of sets
and what brought me here
was opportunity um and
i found it through people that i've been
working with over the years and then
given a chance to do it and it's
wonderful do you feel like there's more
opportunity in the industry these days
for female filmmakers and first-time
filmmakers i think it's a better time
than ever
i want to say it hopefully yes for that
um i'm certainly seeing things
that i haven't seen before and it feels
like it's just opening up in a kind of
incredible way
uh so yeah i'd like to see you i wanted
to ask you all about working with one of
my uh
favorite actresses juliette lewis um
because like you know an hour into this
movie i was like
juliette lewis has been in this thing
for like one minute like you don't you
do not catch julianne lewis and stick
her in the mood for one minute
so i was so delighted that she was
heavily featured in this third act
karen how did you land her in the movie
and then you know the the three of you
like
what was it like working with with uh
such a legend
can i just say something when i read the
script i told
karen right away i wasn't even sure i
was being casted yet but i was like
hey that character did you think of
juliet lewis because i feel like that
would be
perfect for her and she was like
actually yes
i've actually been thinking about it and
yeah totally
you get the film you get it this is it i
was like yeah
yeah we were the same mind i mean
basically
i didn't think of her while i was
writing it but when i was done
and it was time to cast i was like who's
more badass and we need to save the day
than julia lewis like it was so obvious
that
she was the right person for this part
so
uh i just reached out to her she read
the script and the next thing i knew
we were on the phone and she was excited
and passionate
and getting her playing tickets together
so
lucky me you know we needed someone
iconic for this woman and
uh there's no better badass
she is such a badass i it was insane
working with her and doing that that
long scene that we have together that's
it was just like i i was in
awe of her and she was so dedicated and
passionate about something and
passionate about the movie and the fact
that she she did just want to do this
because
because i think it is a movie like you
read it and you're
you're so drawn to it especially being a
woman it's it's
it's it gives off so many
beautiful relevant messages that need to
be
told and need to be told to the world so
i think anyone would be drawn to it no
matter who
who they are and you know it's just it's
just one of those
scripts and stories what was the best or
toughest part for all of you and uh
shooting in in croatia so far away from
home no tough honestly
just like i think the water in
and the insanely green and blue
and just the colors are so vibrant there
that i really felt as though
even after i left i i don't know still
for sure if i was truly
there in croatia i feel as though the
entire thing was surreal from the second
i was looking outside of the window of
the plane and the film sort of lends
itself to that as well which i think is
a perfect mesh between the two by the
landscape
and the film itself but i just feel like
i was taken on this wild journey it
helped so much with the
emotional preparation and with the
landscape that we were really creating
there in that world
and i i mean creations are lovely and
amazing and so i just felt like it
it only benefited the film and myself
well said you should be the spokesperson
for the croatian tourism
i would never tell anyone not to do it
my favorite my favorite bit was the
farmer's market in croatia
that honey that lavender honey ah the
lavender honey i
just ran out brought back
five pots of honey i just ran out
um oh there is one thing that's hard
about croatia as a producer of the film
there are 30 different kinds of wind in
croatia and heaven
and one of them came in and uh
demolished our entire class and it was
the one called
hugo or hugo and uh that was pretty
dramatic
but we had already shot it out so it was
okay
wow okay i know that um
karen and grace one of uh my favorite
exchange in the movie
is uh you know when when you and me are
are duking it out and she
said says i made you into a hero you
made me do a psychopath it's the same
thing
can you sort of talk about what that
exchange sort of meant to
both of you i that's one of my favorite
parts
of the movie i love that scene so much
and i love i love marcia and anna's
dynamic throughout the whole thing um
but i really loved that moment i mean
i i weirdly saw it as like a breakup
scene as well
but but mostly it was anna realized who
she was
um and she realized that
she can stand for what she believes in
and
fight for it without a war
and um and i love that that aspect of in
that turning point
and her saying you know you can't you
won't be winning anymore
and honestly i i can live with that
because it's
it's not about winning um and
and anna needed to come you know i saw i
saw all of the women as parts of
of her and marsha was the the fighter
within her
and anna needed to be encountered with
that to
to bring it out and herself and go back
to the real world and she didn't need a
new life here she didn't need this new
life she just needed to
fine-tune her real one and get back
there so
i really i really love that exchange and
mia is just
a genius so i love her so much did the
three of you ever feel like
sirens in a sense sort of calling men to
their deaths
100
i think i mean karen maybe wants to
speak on this but i mean that was a
major point of
inspiration for our roles and um the
entirety of the plot so i mean karen if
you want to talk about it
yeah i mean sirens are fascinated with
virus
i think i always was drawn to greek
mythology addiction mythology
it's where women are most unapologetic
and formidable and powerful center of
the story
so the sirens were alluring to me
and then i was researching another film
and i learned
that women in world war ii actually
became broadcasters
to have radio shows that would
demoralize the men
and it's an actual thing that happens
with access sally and jose rose and
others and
i just thought oh my god like the myth
of desire is
still with us in this way and
i'm fascinated with that i know this
film is very dreamlike i feel like it's
open to interpretation almost i'm
wondering
what you're hoping viewers will take
away from this experience
i really deeply dedicated this though to
all the girls i know
who didn't make it and i want
coral boys everybody to
feel that even in darkest
times um there is
a way you can survive and find your
voice
and a lot of what happens
that's a good message to have uh right
now um i'm curious if any of you ever
worked like a crappy job like the one
that anna works in this
you kidding me movie
i don't think there's any crappy jobs
there's only crappy attitude
you're just the crappy boss you know
it's like i actually love
my job working you know in a kitchen
and it's busy and it's fun when you love
the people and
there's nothing wrong with you know
honest goes back to that job without
becoming something other than yourself
necessarily it's
you know i think of one of someone who
loves to work i think that all these
women love to work
and they're workers and so and i'm a
worker i love to work for something i
like more
always kind of working so yeah there is
no crappy job so it goes completely
right but there can be people
that ruin your job for you and so that's
what it's about havana i wanted to ask
you i read that a portion of the
proceeds
from your jewelry line go to you know
women's organizations
i'm wondering if you felt like this film
was a piece of activism art
180 it is i think that
this piece to me what's what i love
about the pieces it's super
interpretable
but for me personally in my
interpretation when i first read it
it could be seen as the death of second
wave feminism it could be seen
as a path towards a more nuanced
understanding of gender binaries
i think that all of that within the
feminist conversation is something that
i mean karen really drums up
symbolically in this film
and i think that it can spark
significant conversations about sort of
where we're headed in terms of feminism
and
as a society and where we've been and
what what the fall
the fallouts are from where we have been
and where we can go i feel like
i don't know nothing for me is without
symbolism and activism so
that could also just be my personal read
on it i don't want to speak on behalf of
the whole film
but for me personally yes i got a part
of it um
i became a part of it because of that
underlying message message
and idea and symbolism so yes for me yes
grace i know that you're doing that uh
limited series nine perfect strangers
which has like half of hollywood in it
uh what can you tell us about
where you fit into that show what your
role is or anything
uh it's a crazy crazy little story
um it's so it's about a wellness retreat
that nicole kidman runs
and these nine strangers kind of come
together i'm going there for
grief grieving purposes i'm there with
my parents because i lost
a brother to suicide um three years
prior so we're kind of going for that
and everyone else is there for specific
reasons
and um all hell breaks loose
but um it's it's funny it's sad it's
it has a little bit of everything so i'm
very curious and excited to see how it
see how it turns out i can't wait to see
it uh hopefully later this year
um soko i know you're you're a singer as
well and that you just dropped a new
album of your own which feel free to
plug but i'm curious what
what should i be listening to give me
some recommendations here spotify me
oh you gotta check out soco's new record
it's called feelings please
give it a lot of plays on spotify it's
amazing
um i love the new record of
uh adrian lanker
yes so good uh from
big thief um her voice is incredible and
i've been
really into this lately and also uh
my friend of mine then they they just
put a new song out cole
their their project is called habits and
the new song is beautiful
so that's might have been lately
i'll add it to the list um and then uh
karen is there anything that you're
working on next i know
you know this movie hasn't even come out
yet it's just about to make its festival
debut
but do you have any scripts in in the
drawer that you're going to dust off now
i have three in the dirt and uh i have
a rather condemned friendly one so you
know we're all trying to figure out the
landscape of how to choose how to work
in this new world which will not be able
forever but um i am thinking of
uh pivoting from a much larger campus
that
i feel like mayday is sort of an
explosion
and i think my next film will be similar
and it'll be about extraordinary women
but
it's more of an important i did mean to
ask about that was this film shot prior
to the pandemic or dirt like how did the
pandemic affect things at all
it was shot prior to the symptoms we
ended in december
of 2019 i guess and
yeah we had no idea what was coming
thank god we got to do it
and um we've got to do it in a big way
and uh then i had to very quickly visit
to
uh my post-production my editor and i we
all had to
in 24 hours make our apartments into
editing be completely remote
figure out each part the mix
the compositions the composers
the color and you know each one how do
you do it
how do you do it and um i'm not alone
i'm sure
we'll talk about that we manage
you know independent filmmakers and
incredibly reformed
people we did it
and before i let everybody go how did
you all feel when you got the news
that this movie got into sundance uh i
mean it i know we're not all there in
park city but it's still much i was
gonna say
personally bummed out we couldn't be in
park city
but i'm so happy sundance was doing it
and pulling it off
because they easily could have just said
oh wait until next year you know
and tabitha jackson is her first theater
meetings as a festival
and imagine you think you're gonna throw
a you know a festival and all of a
sudden
you're not and you have to do it this
way and she's doing a beautiful job
so um here's to her indeed um
well congratulations to all of you on
the film mayday premieres at the
sundance film festival make sure to
check it out
thanks for all thank you yeah thank you
all for coming i bungled the last line i
was so close